في السنوات السابقه صراحه
ومتعامل 2003 و2005 الى الان
المكون الصعب ايه انا معاناه كبيره كما هي
بقيه المكونات الاخرى
فقط تعرض العديد من ابناءه الى الخطف
والختي والسرقه مما اضطر العديد منهم
للهجره خارج العراق ومن كذلك اذا قسم منهم
الى الشمال العراق للتامين
وحمايه نفسيه وكذلك همم عائلتهم او
اهلهمم ويقدر عدد العوالات يهاجرات
العوائل وصلت الى العلاف وهمم يوم همم
يقيمون في عده دول في اوروبا في امريكا
همم وكذلك منهم الان في دول الانتظار في
سوريا وفي الاردن وتركيا ينتظرون اللجوء
الى الدول الاخرى للاسف كان الاهتمام
الحكومات المتعاقبه لفترات السابقه
احتمال ليس بالمستوى المطلوب بلقليات فلا
يوجد هناك حمايه للاقليات ولا لحد الانمي
شارع قانون حمايه الاقليات اييييه اليوم
الاهم هو توفر عنصر الامن والامان ثم بقيه
الامور الاخرى كي يشعر ابناء المكون
اوليات
من هناك اهتمام بهمم وان الدوله حريصه على
تواجدهم في البلد
يعني ولو انا ما احب اقول للاقليات احب
اقول العراقيين كثيرون العراقيين غادروا
البلد
حالهم حال الكثير من العراقيين اللي
غادروا البلد لكن نجيء على شغله القوانين
قانون الاحوال الشخصيه اللي هو مستمد اصلا
من الشريعه الاسلاميه
شرعا في 1958
58 لحد الان
الزمن تغير واخذ مدايات
بالتطور كبيره
في هذا في تلك الحقبه الزمنيه لم تكون
معاهدات حقوق انسان ولا اكو حقوق انسان
متضمنه بالقوانين وبقي قانون الاحوال
الشخصيه العراقيه
مثل ما هو
وظيفه له فقره
البطاقه الوطنيه الموحده
الماده 26 ثانيه منها اللي هي اسلمت
الاطفال القاصرين
احنا هي
الهجره
لمن الام غير المسلمه
المتزوجه
تتزوج وهي على ذمه زوجها
غير المسلم السابق هي قانون
وتسلم منها حضانه الاطفال لانها غير امينه
على تربيه اطفالها هذا قانون قانون
الاحوال الشخصيه